好,謝謝,謝謝大家的時間
然後我回顧一下上週的市場
等一下我們把這個客腦不管
我回顧一下上週的市場
然後那個
其實最近以來
就是我們需要 Systematic的倉位的賣出還是很重要的
我總結一下上週的情況,然後這一週
因為GTC在開始嘛
我建議大家比較多看一下GTC最近的進程
然後
對半導體的這個東西GTC還是非常重要
然後其實現在這兩週的話
或者接下去一個月吧,我覺得市場繼續
最中心的事情還是打到
這個
一老河美國的熱衝突到底會走成什麼樣子
我先說一下
大家對
這個衝突裡面最擔心的兩件事情,第一個就是
利率會怎麼走,就通常會變成什麼樣子,然後利率會怎麼走
上週,其實上週和再上週吧,因為這個賬金打了兩多星期了
然後上週再上週的話,兩個星期以來
我們看到Found and rate就是短期的利率基本上都處於
像英國的話是10個Standard deviation的變化
就因為你短期利率本來
預測都是很高的,你基本不怎麼動的,對吧
然後呢,在本來大家有一個很嗨,很多人開始壓住這個英國會降息
然後經過了,就是到年底的短期利率,經過了10個防差的波段
也就是大規模的倉位在下注,就是我們會進入一個Standard deviation
就智障
對智障這個事情我之前講過,我個人覺得是不太會
因為智障的傳遞其實需要先傳遞到通脹
然後傳送通脹傳送到那個核心通脹
然後傳送到核心通脹同時,其實失業情況已經開始變得不好了
然後這個東西本身會offside一部分
就是會抵消一部分核心通脹的上升
然後呢,那個就業和通脹裡面的這個連處其實更多的會選擇就業
就是這是他們通常的選擇
但今年的事情有很多不確定性
就是那個真的把海峽封掉
我大概會說一下它實際的這個影響
真的把海峽封掉的話
那個如果特別是封很長時間的話
這個影響還是很惡劣的
然後冰箱還有點不確定呢
就是現在這個美聯儲主席跟那個跟川普基本上是撕破臉
所以最終他會絕怕會不會下去
然後他會不會在他下去之前採取什麼樣的行動
這個不太好講
因為現在就美國的話左右智障
包括這次你對伊朗的這個戰爭
包括那個就美國國內很多議題上的左右的分歧
他們要投票投票人要要id
這件這個safe metal can add過不了
所以呢就是大家的左右這針其實還是很激烈
那個包括在聯儲內部的政治道上也很厲害
所以最終聯儲採取什麼樣的政策也會有一些變數
那我先說一下這個油價影響
就是油價影響
這個是一個高盛的research
但是呢基本上油價的影響在石油漲每漲10%
這個補給的石油
這個這個是那個cloud把我直接抓出來出去
基本上石油每次漲10%左右
然後會讓那個pc動0.2
然後會讓核心pc動0.04
你們這麼算
那麼現在在海峽內的這個石油
大概是一個什麼規模呢
就是大概是一天走19到21個million barrel
原來就是19198萬到2100萬
我們用那個ambient million barrel來算
就是19原來是每天走19到21個million
然後現在情況大概走一個million以下
所以你說它是不是有通航有可能有那麼一點
有一些伊朗自己知道水雷埋在哪裡
所以它的船可能悄悄地趕開到中國去
去賣一點油
伊朗自己產油其實沒有那麼大
它的出口大概是1.5個million
就是原來是大概1.5million barrel的出口量
然後但是呢
它在那個海峽裡面埋水雷
或者是用無人機器洗
這個船隻
因為船隻本身一個是商業保險上去
第二個船隻的船長也不需要冒這個風險
我打工工我何必被炸死
那麼他們這些人呢
就說現在頂著沒有開沒有通航
大概每天這樣的話
會少掉將近將近20個million
用現在那個IEA同意了
就是SPF放出來的這個儲備油
SPF放出來大概現在
就是120天說是放400million
就400m
400m
相當於每天放2.5到4
那3.3去源於它的這個進程
所以一開始的話
會放了稍微少一點
後來可能情況嚴重會放多一點
那它放的規模就是2.5
然後再把俄羅斯的這個原油
雲一部分過來
因為俄羅斯原來有一部分被禁了
被禁了其實也是流通到市場上
可能賣給中國或者是賣給伊朗
但是它把它可以讓它補進
那麼就是多一份出來
俄羅斯大概能夠多個零點
零點3到零點5
整個規模肯定是在補充的量
在三個million以下
少掉一個million
就能夠通行一個million
補充的規模在三個million
然後禁少大概16個million
這個規模很恐怖的
16個million的那個禁少16個million
如果維持21天的話
那個就是303
就是330個million
然後這個相當於是
如果維持20天的話
就維持到月底了
再維持三個星期
再維持三個星期的話
就可以讓全球所有的
我們叫commercial oil inventory
商業的用油就減少大概50%
商業用油的儲料減少50%
價格真正上升
適當demand
就需求被減掉的時候
就會導致恐慌性的上升
這個我們看到net
天鑽石的net
就那個存儲
net
然後DRAM
他們這些東西漲的時候也是一樣的
就是因為老黃把
大部分的卡都買掉了
買H&M的卡和產能都買掉
買掉以後
那個consumer以來
從那個電子消費品
他就沒有產能了
比方說那個中國造的這個電子
一輩車和那個手機
像是小米的手機
華為手機
華為叫榮耀手機
他們都已經沒有買不到內存了
買不到內存影響他出貨了
就是要減掉這一部分的需求
當減需求的時候
價格就會暴漲
因為這是恐慌性的上升
所以現在原油價格
有沒有完全反應
如果21天
這個是GS的base case
然後有沒有反映
21天的石油斷行
現在其實沒有完全反映
因為21天石油斷行之後
IEA還會繼續放油
然後是可以讓這個市場
叫做carver恢復的
但是如果說超過21天
弄了三四個月
那麼這個油價就很難恢復
但就說的比較可怕一點
就是當這個需求完全
就是那個叫用掉一半的商業的存油
和你用掉80%的商業存油是不一樣的
當你用掉一半之後
需求就開始變少了
它必須要減掉那些需求
這個時候油價就會漲很多
所以油價上升確實是現在
就是說你短期打完的
肯定是沒有關係的
油價上升長期的油價上升
如果全而不絕
確實是會導致很多的問題
第一個問題就是導致可能會衰退
然後導致我們之前講到的CDO
就是那個信貸市場
其實美國我們這次看那個GTC
英文拿說一萬億收入的
然後那個市場
其實沒有把它股價推上去太多
背後的擔心就是CAPEX會怎麼樣
那個大的Hyperscaler的CAPEX
就是錢從哪裡來
因為錢最終都是從Private
就是Private Credit那邊來的
就是那個信貸那邊來
那信貸的情況是怎麼樣的
就是說如果說油價上升了很多的話
那對信貸市場是會有衝擊的
就是會減少他們這一部分
獲取資金的能力
大家CDS都會上去
然後反過來會抑制AIS的CAPEX
其實最後就是英文打印力都是沒有問題的
但是抑制的勢必要說是CAPEX
然後印製CAPEX的時候影響整個市場的情緒
就不是有個跌下去
所以油的問題有沒有現在Pricing最差的情況
有沒有Pricing差的情況
我覺得油現在油價已經定價到
我們可能這個月就不能通好了
但是油價肯定是沒有定價
我們兩三個月都不能通
因為美國兩三個月都搞不定它肯定沒有
那麼這個就是要大家對GeoPolitico的理解
然後自己去判斷這個事情
我個人是覺得那雖然把最高領袖打死
但是在海峽通航這件事情上
其實兩邊都拿著這個東西
它最後最後的一個籌碼在談
因為美國沒有下死手
美國雖然把他那個Harmony-1給炸死了
就是他對他政權本來是想直接把你顛覆掉
但是對於伊朗自己出口原油最大的港河
他其實沒有下手把你炸掉
因為把你炸掉以後
你伊朗一點也都出不去
就是他也沒有封鎖
就是讓你伊朗的船不能出去
其實伊朗的船要出去
它就不能夠在海峽裡面拼命的亂布雷
因為它控制海峽的手段
它不是靠它的什麼導彈什麼
這個隱暗的所有的火力點
你只要開火5分鐘之內
美軍就把你給炸掉
所以它現在很多都敲不珍惜出去買點水雷
這個是騷擾性很強
就是戰鬥力不強
但是騷擾性很強
因為你在一碗米裡面撒一包沙子
你要把這個沙子挑出來的難度肯定很大
對美國受到這個東西的影響
如果說一直不同行
美國受到這個東西的影響
會比歐洲、日本、中國要小很多的
美國手上是有石油的
它每天出口4個米鏈
就像整個波斯灣出去是20個米鏈
美國出口是4個米鏈
當然它要進口一些油
因為它用的是light的
它要sower light
它還是需要進口一些重油的
所以但重油這個東西
在加拿大和在南美也都有
就是從美國角度來說
它如果做很極端的事情
比方說它限制石油出口
我們WTI有打開
它限制石油出口
這個裡面受傷害
其實最大的是那些缺油的國家
缺油就歐洲、中國、日本
還有韓國那些都是缺油的
美國是不缺油的國家
只是它會出現inflation
會出現通脹
會影響它資本市場
但是它本質上從戰略上來說
它沒有那麼缺這個東西
然後說一下對通脹影響
如果說情況很惡化的話
對通脹的Headline inflation
影響是很大的
但是對於核心CPI影響沒有那麼大
那這就是為什麼
我們看到利率市場
我們說10年期利率
10年期利率其實一直在上升了
上到4.2、4.2、4.2、4.5
然後在4.8、4.2、4.2、4.5之間
上升到一個比較高的水平
其實就pricing了
我們可能命令智障
但是我覺得智障並不是一個選項
因為你通脹不管到多少水平
那個最後看的是核心通脹率
核心通脹到核心通脹的傳導
因為油價和進口商品
它的這個傳導是不是很有效的
它並不是就是大家往往拿
現在這一次的危機
去類比2022年俄羅斯取打烏克蘭
然後把通脹給點爆了
現在的基礎和當時是不同的
當時的基礎是
我們已經放了很長時間前
利率在exceptionally low
然後流動性一直在央行在硬潛
然後油價和物價一上升
這個
然後之前還在做很多fittical policy
就是還在做財政之處
所以一旦有一個油頭開始上漲的時候
其實本來這個通脹的這個泥土
就是漲在這個土上那個財貨
就已經堆了很高了
所以火焰就燒起來
但現在並不是這樣
現在10年期利率在2.4幾
然後利率在相對來說
比較高的位置
特別在美國
它是要降息的
在歐洲是一個比較均衡的位置
但是在美國肯定是一個比較高的位置
因為你看上上上上星期的那個能防培羅
然後看最近一段時間的就業數據
除了那個desperate調整那一層
就上上著那個就業數據其實非常差
根據那個就業數據
美國應該今年要降三次
但是像現在包括傑平摩根在內
其實調整了它的預期
傑平摩根覺得今年可能搞不好要升下
當然苟問高盛的話還是覺得會降息
那我個人的看法是
它沒有能力去升
哪怕短期裡面PCB變了很高
核心PCB動的時候
它肯定沒有沒有能力升息
因為現在就業市場
本質上美國就業service市場是很差的
然後在如果油價引爆
如果是現在我們定價一個非常不利的行情
就是油價引爆資本市場開始下跌
如果發生這樣的事情
那麽什麽樣的東西最容易超低的
就最容易超低就是債
就我年初的時候覺得今年其實
我不知道會打仗
但是如果不打仗
不發生這件事情的話
今年是債的大年
就是怎麽看
就是長短利率都應該往下滑下去的
這跟供應面有關
我之前講過
跟那個國債本身的供應面有關
然後和本來今年的deflating
也就是整個經濟同外面的設定有關
那麽今年債的大年
會在就如果說短期裡面
讓過多的price的執掌
那麽我覺得是會超低
是應該去買國債
所以國債我覺得現在大家太多的低估了
就是最終這一次的石油上升
和特朗普加關稅是一曲同工的
就是我增加了外來商品的價格
所以我增加了通賬
我在年底可能會增加0.5
最惡惡劣的情況
那個就是石油漲到150塊錢以上
我一直在那裏
在年底或增加0.5的核心通賬
同時的話我會讓經濟變得更弱
但是你不可能說
伊朗這個問題又永遠不解決
打一年兩年三年解決
不知道不可能的
這是實驗的問題
就是你要麽就是幾個星期
要麽就是正常情況
要麽就是幾個月
就是說當大家特別擔心通賬問題
然後利率上升的時候
其實這個背後真正的威脅
是失業會變得很差
然後就業變得很差
經濟變得非常差
所以一旦一次性的危機被解除了
打仗解除了
就和當時關稅解除一樣
就是它會發生一下子的大規模的反彈
跟關稅還有點不同的是
這一次解除之後
就是說還是會在經濟基本面上造成一些影響
所以除了資本市場反彈以外
利率還是會下行
所以現在的利率
怎麼說現在利率是一個偏高的位置
但是沒有到一個可以直接做空利率
就做多抖擂權的位置
做多抖擂權的位置更好是
整個市場能夠給出更大的壓力
就是更大的彈性
現在市場有點像你在張公大劍
就是把公權往後拉
那肯定沒有拉到最後
那拉到最後這個反彈是很穩
那我們同樣的道理
就是我說一下
上週我們提到過市場的Position
其實我這邊沒有畫TOPPO不高的
就是這個是上週的
TOPPO不高的
就是說我們現在在盤口掛單
現在盤口掛單還是很少的
然後上週我們預期要賣21個別臉
然後最後賣了20.5個別臉
基本上Inline就是賣了200多億
S&P就賣200多億
然後賣了200多億以後
整個S&P的倉位
現在基本上是持平的
我沒有把CTA的東西畫上來
但是我說一下
就是現在基本上CTA的倉位是持平的
就是短短
然後就短期short term的momentum
中期的momentum
現在都flip變做空了
長期的momentum在6300多
還沒有辦法這麼快被flip
所以整體的我們叫做CTA這些momentum
是平倉
就是它沒有做多也沒有做空
基本上會不會做多
然後在下方的gama還是附的
然後我看一下
因為我這邊忘記寫到PD上去
那個下方的gama大概在5%左右
5%左右的話是兩個別臉
就是這個你看它規模不是很大
但是它是你一旦跌到那個
我才是瞬間長出來的
所以你如果往下跌
那個過程中間它實質的會加速
你的上漲或者下跌
然後盤口還是比較輕
所以我們說上週的這個
Position set up
現在有沒有改善呢
從CTA的倉位上來說改善
因為CTA現在是flip的
但是gama position和現在的這個
盤口掛單還是相對比較少
那麼這一週因為有GTC
很多半導體的樂觀情緒都很多
所以上週其實市場下跌的幅度
遠遠比我預期的小很多
照理來說要賣出20個20.5個別臉的CTA市場
絕對不是這樣一個跌幅
特別在Naked Gama的時候
因為跌幅要大很多
所以感覺這個就是retail買入股票的
這個機器機性很高
那麼這一週還要考驗一下
因為這一週賣280萬
280個28個別臉
然後在S&P上
如果你把它擴展到
擴展到整個美股可能是300多
然後你如果把它擴展到
那個全部的股票可能是幾來多
Global CTA
所以Global CTA
美國在中間可能佔一半
但是Global CTA現在的賣出的量
是非常大的
就這個是一個相對來說
相對來說我們從position上要關注的
那麼就像我剛剛講的
現在你等於是在張公了
你就拉這個公權
拉到底
因為CTA就不過被你全部打成富的
哪怕只有做多的力量
這個時候的反彈一樣會很悶的
就是和去年4月份有點像
所以一方面關注市場上的頭寸和倉位
第二方面就關注這個海峽的
就是那個Hosmos海峽的情況
因為我確實對軍事上不是很瞭解
但是我的感覺是
伊朗可能沒有大規模的反擊力量
就是但是它會一直買水來噁心你
我果然說那個CTA的情況
CTA一段上個月Global全球
CTA賣了80個別點
然後整個上個月
然後這一周
就是Discomming Week要賣70個別點
所以這一周的賣壓和我們叫做
上一周的賣壓是相對比較大
這一周比上一周更大一點
因為整一個月
你看其實市場橫沾那裡不動
中間有一部很大原因
就CTA在慢慢買
然後上面有卡碼我衝不上去
對吧
散戶只下來來朝底
那條也很險
但是CTA的集中賣壓
在這兩個星期爆發出來
所以要把CTA Flip成負的
所以我是覺得這一周的就是賣盤挺多的
然後這一周賣完
然後這下面整一個月的
至少賣出的速度就開始減緩
所以我看到一個Swivel Line
就是Swivel Line走著
你看到一個曙光
後面一個曙光
但是Retail接盤的動力
我感覺還是很大
就在股票上面接盤的動力還是很大
然後這個和Private Credit
是有一些聯動
就Private Credit再跌很奇怪
然後股票Private
跌得更多一點
Private再跌
但股票接盤還是挺多的
然後說到賽合信貸問題
這個是我剛講
對於AI KAPEX
對於AI中間比較重要的原因
因為有說是美國如果把它翻成82開
那麼傳統的8和新進的2
那個新進的2才是真正缺錢的
需要去降息
然後需要美國放鬆留銀根
然後需要那個銀行去Deregulation
然後提供更多的資金
本質上新的需要很多的錢
然後去取代就的
因為一臺電腦就可以感覺
我這個BPD就用Cloudy寫的
然後就可以讓那個取代很多原來的人
但是原來的行業
其實沒有那麼缺錢
所以美國處於這樣的一個狀態
裡面Private Credit
能不能繼續融刀更多錢
是後面很重要的一個關注
那快捷市場
從下跌
就Private Credit下跌
CDS變寬
其實這個事情從去年年底就開始了
然後中間最早是
向Oroco這些AI KAPEX領獵的
然後接著的話
那個大家擔心那個軟件
軟件的exposure
在所有Private Credit裡面
可能下完30萬
就是不同的基金持倉會有點不一樣
比方說GSCM就高升的變可能會少一點
但是有一些會多一點
大概在25%到30%之間
所以對快捷
對於債的影響肯定很負面
然後第二個趨勢是
有可能跟AI來有關
也有可能就是AI來了
然後信息更加容易收集了
很多新一代的投資人
開始選擇不去買基金
去自己做投資
這個在牛市裡面也不停普遍
然後在美國這一輪裡面
也是我覺得也慢慢變成
更加強的一個風氣
作為一個基金
它一般來說
至少會持個23%式的信用債
然後因為信用債本身
和等於做一個自然配置
它不會完全是買股票
它有很大基金完全買股票
它會配一部分信用債20、30
但是散戶只會配1%
所以這個就是看到
為什麼資金就從我們叫technical
就技術戰術層面
資金一直從Private Sector裡面去redeem
很多的基金它都設了
比方說一個月redeem5%的cap
就是最多能夠redeem5%
所以一直有看到
under news看到很多的基金要去收回
收回不了
然後指數
然後下一次開放的時候
因為這些債它都持有的
不能賣
然後指足
或者下次乾脆就不讓你收回了
不讓收回導致這些客戶
更加想去收回那些能收回
所以在Private Sector裡面
有這樣一個問題
就是投資人的價格變化
然後導致很多的債相關的基金
其實被收回的比較多
但是有一部分這樣的錢
就反過來又回去買到股票去了
所以我們在股票上面看到
retail的錢還是不停的打朝地
那麼最終能不能
就是AI需要的錢是很大很大
所以最終這個錢就是CAPEX
它總是會到一個點上
然後說我CAPEX grow變慢
這個點有可能發生了今年
有可能發生在明年
所以這個中間也會對AI造成一下的影響
就是現在是到了那個大的科技公司的
free cash flow變少
free cash flow變少之後
它再要去做這個CAPEX投入
其實是需要金融給它做槓桿
就像我們當時出表
要去給它出表做槓桿
出表做槓桿
現在靠的就是這些Private Fund
然後說什麼Appolo
Bloow這些人
那這些基金現在其實
因為信貸的問題受到影響
所以沒有那麼快建立這麼大的表外優
因為AI的需求是明年可能要8000億
這兩年可能要到2萬億
這兩三年可能要到2萬多億
明年要8000億的AI CAPEX
所以這也是回答一個問題
就是說為什麼昨天黃仁勳說
我業績1萬億
就是我軟約到1萬億去了
然後那個市場並沒有那麼完蛋
但是要知道一個點
就是我補充一下關於英偉大的一個說法
就是其實雖然說AI CAPEX有可能會
增速有可能會下降
增速下降
但是對半導體公司沒有那麼負面
因為整個半導體的投資其實分成
我之前好像也說過這問題
就是分成兩部分
一部分是土建
這個東西是要二十年折舊的
還有一部分是買卡
其實你想買卡的回本周期是非常快的
買卡在H100可能一年半
然後那個B系列可能一年半兩年
就我如果不知道
因為我這還沒算沒有定價
但是這其實根據每一度電
你能夠租出去的租金是多少
這樣來定價的
所以其實它的買卡回本周期
現金流周期是挺快的
CAPEX做CAPEX的公司
包括AUROCO在內
其實它沒有辦法
就是它現在沒有
沒有看到這麼好的那個字
就是我們就ROE或者ROI
其實主要是它也在做很多土建
等於我在玩大風
我要把地線買了
然後他們才建樓
你走進來才能付錢
但是買地買完地
你走現在是買地這個投入時間
是要攤銷長時間的
然後買完地要一年半以後
你才能放卡
所以它有個周期回報
然後讓它的ROE看上去很低
如果是CAPEX變緩
其實有可能發生的事情
是CAPEX變緩的時候
它的ROE會變高的
因為直接買卡
它ROE就變高了
現在建完的儲存
就是建完的算力中心
缺大概還是缺
今年可能還缺300多萬張卡
明年可能缺400萬多萬張卡
就是我們說的那個
就是我們說的英文來GPU
GPU的單位
還缺大概這麼規模的卡
所以
Yes這個CAPEX的速度下降
有可能會對AI
AI-CAPEX相關的公司也會有一些影響
但是真正業績出來的時間
我發覺其實沒有那麼大影響
就是可能還是沒有那麼大影響
後面一步AI開始要證明的
其實就是收錄
包括你Allocore這些
我們現在在做CAPEX的人
還有就是前方的模型
現在我們看到的是
模型對於Token的需求
確實這幾個月是指數級的意義在上升
就是大規模的
我覺得大規模的
這個是會產生一個社會效應級別的改動
就是大規模的白領
或者是腦力勞動者
從現在勞勞動者都是
腦力勞動者大部分都是民主黨支持者
這些人會大規模的實驗
所以這個甚至會改變整個voter base
改變整個voter
就是整個美國的政治環境都是會改變
也就是說你今天看到美國可能很
很右
馬上要波亂反正
要變回左
對吧
但是變右可能是一個更加長的軸氣
這個不光是在美國發生
在中國也會發生
也就是我們以前
我以前就忽然說一句
我以前投過一個公司作表
說做保險產品比較
那保險產品現在輸入進去
讓Clock和你做比較
可能就幾分鐘
我們以前編一個網站
就是帶前端後端的網站
可能怎麼說要幾個星期吧
也好幾個人
現在我自己放在辦公室裡
可能30分鐘是寫清楚需求
30分鐘半腦的一個小時就變好了
所以這個是大規模的人
可能會
這個是簡單的
就不是
就是說不是那麼Operation了
但我說大規模的人會失效
像寫這種PPT原來投行的小朋友
也要寫一段時間了
現在PPT都是Block生成
所以AI的需求還是會在
但是這個中間會有一些bump
短期裡面的最大的關注
就是這個戰爭的影響
判斷一下大概會有多長時間
因為看美國和伊朗兩邊的
其實現在最後談判籌碼沒死掉
就是他們還保留著等行
上美國沒把人家倒下了
然後伊朗沒有瘋狂的部隊
真的把那個海峽給封閉了
所以要看他最後談
或者是最後大家打成什麼樣子
好吧
我們下一星期再看一下
再聊一下新的這個倉位
我覺得現在的倉位
就是走了七八成
就是這個賣出的壓力
走了七八成
就是時間上走了七八成
我今天講時間比較長
然後我們要不今天先這樣
就不做Q&A了
謝謝大家